voici mike horn
ah oui
bonsoir bonsoir mon corps personnage
dans les français maintenant oui comme
une vache espagnole va chez scania la
grille alors justement vous êtes né en
1966 à johannesburg en afrique du sud
alors avant de parler de votre aventure
qui est exceptionnel mike horn
vous pensez quoi de ce kit venu
l'afrique du sud aujourd'hui le pays
arc-en-ciel dont parle
nelson mandela où les blancs sont restés
il ya toujours des indiens des métis des
noirs est ce que ça marche
écoute je viens de rentrer de l'afrique
du sud après quoi être trois ans dans
l'arctique
et puis je voulais rester il ya beaucoup
d'espoir là il ya beaucoup de
développement il ya beaucoup
d'investisseurs qui arrive et puis je
crois que ça marche bien
né à tignes mondiale à je le connais un
peu il a vraiment fait un bon travail et
puis j'espère que targon béquilles il va
continuer avec ça et puis on doit juste
faire d'autres petites choses pour
décida et tout ça mais parfois il faut
mettre un peu plus d'argent là dedans et
puis un peu plus de promotions grève
dans tous les cas nelson mandela a dit
mon fils est mort du sida alors que
souvent en afrique du sud ont dit les
morts de la tuberculose parce qu'on
n'ose pas dire que c'est le sida etc et
nelson mandela a avoué que son fils
était mort du sida 52 ans et 52 ans et
c'est triste mais ma foi donc l'afrique
du sud ça marche
aujourd'hui ouais je crois que ça marche
puis voilà donc mike horn et tout ce
qu'on appelle un aventurier de l'extrême
c'est un type extraordinaire la preuve
il a déjà descendu l'amazone à la nage
il a fait le tour du monde en suivant la
ligne de l'équateur est là et là vous
n'êtes faire vingt mille kilomètres
autour du cercle polaire arctique
c'est la fameuse exposition arctos ce1
alors vous raconter ça dans un bouquin
qui est publié chez x o qui s'appelle
conquérant de l'impossible alors il ya
deux phrases en exergue de ce bouquin la
première c'est une phrase de alexis de
tocqueville
nous appelons impossible ce qui n'a
jamais été tenté
voilà et la deuxième aile et andrée
chedid la grand mère de m
il dit ça pour les plus jeunes
l'impossible est le seul adversaire
digne de l'homme
voilà les deux phrases qui l'a collé en
exergue de 200 bouquin alors au départ
vous êtes d'origine hollandaise c'est
des hollandais qui sont partis habiter
en afrique du sud ouest français on a et
on en est aux landais ouais ouais
pardon comme dave cobb mais je ne pas
dans le même coin mais bon on n'est pas
trop alors votre père était directeur de
lycée c'était annexes springbok il est
mort quand vous aviez 15 ans et votre
mère était enseignante à leurs enfants
vous étiez déjà très sportif mike horn
et son avenir de d'aventuriers se
dessine assez tôt à 8 ans vous rejoignez
en vélo la ferme de votre oncle qui est
située à 300 km de là 300 kilomètres
séparent loi si tu as du temps j'ai
commencé la drogue tour alors quand vous
étiez adolescent vous êtes rentré dans
l'armée vous avez été capitaine des
forces spéciales sud-africaine effet la
guerre en namibie donc ça vous a
effectivement formé à la violence
voilà et puis ensuite vous rentrez dans
la vie professionnelle et la mic torn
est employé par son oncle il fait de
l'import export de fruits et légumes au
départ d'ailleurs vous réaliser une
transaction exceptionnelle sur des choux
qui vous a rapporté énormément d'argent
moi j'ai trop vite trop bien gagner ma
vie mais voilà ça lui plaisait pas parce
que bon il avait plein de blaye n'y
avait pas de but dans la vie est là vous
établissez
anglais mais n'avait pas de cul dans
l'avion c'est ceux là sont chaudes
j'ai donc là vous établissez une liste
des endroits de la jungle et des
étendues glacées ou vous aimeriez aller
et puis vous réunissez tous vos amis un
jour pourquoi j'ai eu tout ce que je
voulais oui mais c'était pas ça que je
voulais et je disais mais ce soir je
fais un grand feu de chez moi
et puis je viens d'acheter un rat
johannesburg un grand maison il ya une
piscine et où je disais à mes potes
écoute vient et puis ce soir je donne
tout ce que j'ai à tous mes potes et
puis on a bu un peu divers et tout ça ma
soeur est avec avocate est là préfèrent
préparer toutes les contraintes
j'ai donné tout à mes amis et puis je me
retrouvais avec un sac à l'aéroport il a
tout donné alors à ce moment là ce n'est
pas connu à ce moment là non mais ces
expériences m'ont live à l'aéroport et
les seuls pays en fait on pouvait aller
quand on était africain du sud sans visa
c'était israël la suisse et l'angleterre
dont il à l'aéroport
à ce moment là il ya un avion qui part
pour la suisse c'est comme ça que vous
vous retrouvez à zurich
exactement correctement sans sans rien
connaître de la langue sans rien
connaître du pays
alors début c'était difficile quand même
vous voyez j'ai commencé il y à il ya
360 km entre zurich et montres ou non et
puis parce que j'ai pas eu de travail
dirigé pas eu l'argent
j'ai décidé de faire ça à pied puis de
passer un peu vers les paysans pour
demander s'il y avait du travail 1 puis
c'est de toujours un peu la même réponse
quand il disait que quoi on n'engage pas
des étrangers
1 et puis là je disais d'accord et
coûteux ouais je continue d'arriver
j'arrivais à montreux j'ai commencé de
volée juste pour rester vivants vous
avez vous évolué des fruits à wayne a il
faut que j'ai dormi dans des étapes j'ai
dormi sous des ponts enfin c'est
incroyable parce que il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire cirque en afrique du
sud
vous faisiez partie de la la classe des
possédants la classe des riches des
blancs à l'époque c'était
ron et puis un jour vous arrivez en
suisse et vous retrouver dans la
position du noir quand dans la position
du du titre capable de africains parce
qu'ils ont bien ri garde un sens
ouais mais coûte c'est sûr c'est sûr que
si tu te retrouves dans la situation un
peu que t'as pas vraiment l'habitude du
dit soient tous rentrer à la maison mais
parce que j'ai eu rien à la maison jeudi
il faut que j'avais mes responsabilités
vous aviez comme on dit brûler vos
vaisseaux c'est à dire que vous n'aviez
plus de maison dans laquelle retournez
donc j'étais obligé de continuer vous
faites des petits boulots vous installez
ensuite vous rencontrer katy qui
deviendra votre votre femme vous
commencez à trouver des sponsors enfin
c'est un courage absolument
extraordinaire et là vous vivez votre
première grande aventure en 1997
traversée de l'amérique du sud la france
il part du pérou il fait déjà 600 bornes
à travers la cordillère des andes mais
comme ça tu vois comment il fait pour y
aller au pérou en avion ouais j'ai une
copain qui était pilote
et puis il fait 600 morts dans la
cordillère des andes jusqu'aux sources
de l'amazone et là vous descendez
l'amazone rélégué c'était 6400 km à la
nage
l'idée c'était dedans fait traverser
l'amérique du sud
ouais en solitaire sans assistance et
puis il des bouées quand même il avait
un truc s'appelle l'hydrospeed c'est une
petite planche que tu sèmes body board
comment dix églises comme ça c'est les
jambes des lycées
là il ya un animal qui est pas mal
intéressant parce que tu peux pas
vraiment faire pipi dans le dos parce
qu'il ya un lien c'est un poisson de
chats mara site dès que tu fais pipi en
fait la green c'est la tirelire entre
les sahraouis où il ya un trou ouais
et puis en fait tu peux pisser dans
l'eau mais il faut regarder ton patelin
c'est comme tu fais chier sur la place
rouge donc il fait quand même six ans il
fait quand même 6400 km à la nage donc
avec son hydrospeed pour descendre
l'amazone jusqu'à l'embouchure de
l'amazone dans l'océan dans le sens
atlantique ses premières aventures d'isa
pris six mois
deuxième grande aventure qui a encore un
exploit absolument unique
le tour du monde en solitaire par
l'équateur son véhicule à moteur à
l'idée c'était de rester sur l'équateur
n'est pas de m'éloigner plus 40000
honorera la ville au sud
et puis de deux parties du gabon et
quand vous quittez le gabon c'est la
première fois que vous vous retrouvez
seul sur un voilier ouais j'ai jamais
j'ai jamais c'est la voile en fait c'est
jésus winch est un fait sur les bateaux
de laurent bourgnon qui est encore pire
il part du gabon pour traverser
l'atlantique est la première fois qu ils
essaiment sur un voilier alors ensuite
bon il ya l'amérique du sud vont
traverser l'amérique du sud l'indonésie
avec les révoltes avec le combat tout ça
faisait un cas extraordinaire et puis
bon voilà vous êtes élu aventuriers du
xxème siècle quand même
ouais pas y avait par contre je crois
c'est pour ça il est bon on a vu donc la
descente de l'amazone à la nage le tour
du monde par l'équateur est là en
février 2002 sert klose donc c'est la
dernière expédition celle que vous
racontez dans votre bouquin conquérant
de l'impossible donc 20000km tour du
cercle polaire arctique
à contre courant et à contrevent alors
on lui dit mais pourquoi quand on fait
vingt mille kilomètres autour du cercle
polaire arctique pourquoi vous le faites
à contre-courant à contretemps qui
s'entend si bien que ça que ça fait
[Applaudissements]
j'adore attend lui dit pourquoi vous le
faites à contre-courant à 80 ans il dit
ben parce que en cas de réussite dans
l'autre sens
j'aurais passé toute ma vie à me
demander comment j'aurai réussi dans le
mauvais sens ouais ouais ça moi je la
mettrais d'échouer un peu contre 1
contre des aliments que d'aller avec les
années ma ville et rue qui dit laissez
c'est tellement dur ce qui fait que
trouvent le courage de surmonter toutes
les épreuves et vous dites je faisais
surmonter parce que j'ignorais quelle
souffrance elle représentait si j'avais
su quelle souffrance j'allais vivre je
l'aurais pas fait vous utilisez des
accessoires aussi à la maison c'est
bizarre on m'écoute je crois j'ai pas du
tout mal y avait il ya des moments qui
est plus dur que d autres mais
aujourd'hui cm c'est mon métier
et puis je fais ça professionnellement
pendant dix ans et puis c'est moi je
vois ça comme tout à fait normal qu'on
fait les courses au programme caddie ou
vous mettez tout comme sa survie alors
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est
qu'avant de faire le tour du cercle
donc voilà il ya l'envers il ya eu un
voyage préparatoire le voyage
préparatoire il dit bon pour me préparer
instance mettre en forme
je vais aller au pôle nord en solitaire
800 morts c'est juste pour s'entraîner
juste pour s'entraîner et la grosse
erreur je n'ai pas eu vraiment choix
c'était un moment que je marchais plus
ça veut dire que mon corps génère plus
de chaleur
et puis je commence à tomber dans
l'hypothermie et puis là c'est la vie
aux ligues lima 1
j'ai enlevé mes move pour attacher mes
chaussures et puis c'est sûr c'est la
dernière fois que je m'enlève mm ouf
tu es là les doigts explose et alors ce
qu'il fait il rentre dans sa tente
il met ses doigts dans le feu parce
qu'ils sont tellement gelée qui les met
dans le feu et est à ce moment là oui il
a eu il a été un peu amputé oui et à ce
moment là et ça sent la viande brûlée et
lui sans rien mais ça sent là ça sent la
viande brûlée alors effectivement là
vous décidé de rentrer donc cette
expédition préparatoire n'a pas été me
et à son père décidé de rentrer pour
sauver vos mains en fait ce soir
exactement il ya un moment que tu dises
mais là maintenant je dois rentrer je
dois réparer mes mains non autrement si
je continue
j'étais à quinze jours du pôle si je
continue je veux permet main et puis je
peux plus rien faire de mal
tout ça parce que tu avais des la
céphalée m crawl et bien accro mais non
ils veulent qu'on marche pas à moi 50
sap est en fait ça peut être bon sans
compter sur vous rentrez on vous ampute
un peu le bout des doigts mais vous
attendez même pas le délai normal vous
partez pour cette fameuse expédition
donc archos et là il ya des épreuves
absolument inouïe suis dit ah c'est par
exemple un moment il va en bateau au
départ de norvège au groenland
il ya un trou dans la coque est là alors
c'est incroyable cirque d'une main et
conduit le bateau de l'autre ils vident
le bateau et il ya les icebergs qui
arrive sur lui les mecs ils au milieu
céline dion et à dormir parce que s'il
dort il pu piloter le bateau un peu plus
vide et le bateau donc voila et puis au
milieu des icebergs comme ça créatif dix
fois un peu on n'a pas vraiment les
choix du foie et puis hein si on veut
arriver à nantes
il faut c'est vrai c'est vraiment un fou
c'est vraiment jouer à chat [ __ ] ou quoi
alors après il traverse se croyait nord
donc ils arrivent ils à la seconde
langue avec une espèce de cerfs-volants
quoi et ça va très vite parce que vous
arrivez à faire d un jour par exemple il
fait 18 heures dans la journée 143 km
donc ça va assez vite vous battez le
record de traversée du groenland
grâce à ce système de cerfs-volants et
puis un jour il ya un vent énorme
looping voilà vous êtes vous et arraché
et arraché par une tempête de vent
exactement là c'était juste un moment
que tu peut plus gérer la surface est
trop grande nommé car et vivant surface
60 70 kilomètres à l'heure et tu peux
plus de sont à voile c'est sûr qu'il ya
un moment que tu vas passer d'eux une
cravate tu vas passer d'un peu de volume
avec le profil assez sûr tu dois te
tombe il s'en sort à chaque fois c'est
extraordinaire
à un moment il arrive dans une région il
doit prendre un bateau pour aller à
calamity belge croit il doit prendre un
bateau et puis bon il ya la glace qui
fait qu'on peut pas naviguer
il fait un détour de 1200 km le mec avec
jets par des tours de 300 m² sur 2200 km
et tout ça à moins 60 dans la nuit
permanente parce qu'en plus de ça il
faut voir ce que si ça ne fait même pas
le jour il neige il fait froid moins 60
il fait nuit voilà malheureusement on a
trois mois de nuit ou n'a pas beaucoup
de soleil ouais on aurait pu y est écrit
sur les sauvetages à bangkok 24 heures
sur 24
et puis là tu peux bien avancé alors
c'est extraordinaire parce que ce sont
des régions où la vie humaine est
impossible circuler seuls qui vivent
là-bas ce sont les inuits
mais ils bougent pas ils restent où ils
vivent sur leur graisse comme les ours
quoi ils vivent tout l'hiver sur leur
glace
ils sont pas cons en attendant qu'il
fasse beau ou toi et lui non lui il
avance là dedans dans ce pays donc même
pas un inuit qui qui fait ce que vous
avez fait quoi c'est parce que les innus
au point compte déjà un ep en plus les
in which has 1
au début de l'hiver et puis l'hiver iris
parce qu'il peut plaisir il voit rien
ouais et puis moi si je restais je crève
et c'est vrai que j'ai été obligé d'un
marché en fait de rester vivant 1
alors quand vous faites ça vous manger
quoi vous manger quoi l'huile d'olive
bord et tout ce qu'on n'a pas droit de
manger bio exactement un demi kilo de
chocolat par jour 1 après dix noix et
puis après muesli qui est prêt à la
maison toute la nourriture est en fête
préparé à la maison
et puis un jour payer environ un jour de
nourriture pèse environ kilos et demi
s'est dit quand je pars pour trois mois
j'ai 150 kg de nourriture
ça c'est sans l'essence main parce que
tu peux crever de soi un yann agacé puis
la neige il faut fonte de la glace
et puis ça aussi tu fonte de la glace et
puis il faut avoir un en ligue défense
pour trois jours ça veut dire que tu
prend 50 lits d'essence fait déjà deux
cents kilos là c'est 200 kilos aurait
plus une question bien sûr c'est juste
le challenge personnel d'avoir la
compagnie je n'ai jamais eu de quoi vous
vivez
je vous ai recommandé sponsorisés
pourfendu je suis sponsorisé
naturellement parce qu'on peut pas
assurer une expédition comme ça ça ça
coûte cher et puis en plus on fait pas
mal de roger fait pas mal de recherches
toutes les matières qui se trouve sur
les marchés aujourd'hui pour ces mois un
peu des premières qu'il teste ligoté que
c'est moi qui devais le petit vêtement
la tente des sacs de couchage indices
qui nous des chaussures de ski si vous
êtes bien dans votre chaussure c'est un
peu grâce à les explorateurs si vous
êtes mal c'est pas grâce à nous c'est
grâce à d autres à cause des autres et
puis après aussi on ne fait pas mal de
réserves sur la réchauffement de la
planète pour voir si je vois des animaux
plus au nord que qui montre plus au nord
à cause de la largement et puis il ya
deux ans
canada j'ai vu pour la première fois
dans l'histoire un grizzly qui a tué un
ours polaire et puis là c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui la glace à être aux lois de
la terre un ours polaire peut nager 100
km mais la glace il ya 150 km
aujourd'hui ça vous dit qu ils sont peu
frustrés ils sont sur la plage il ne
peut pas chasser ils sont affamés des
grizzlies arrive lui son ordre parce
qu'il ya plus à manger au nord qu'au sud
et puis là il rentre dans le territoire
des ours papy voilà les ours les ours
noirs est trop faible et est là et alors
mike votre votre la tente dans laquelle
vous habite elle en quoi les îles et des
zones ils ont à traiter en fait que ça
brûle pas et puis en même temps les
problèmes c'est que tu as tu as quelque
chose en moi 50 que tu peux pas vraiment
plier parce que l'hymne ils ont au moins
50 en -60 situe le pli 2 3 fois sa
casque en hiver tout vient vraiment
cassant et puis on a fait alors et puis
là tu dois faire vachement gaffe quand
tu mec l'attend quand il fait vraiment
trop froid
tamer temps pas de la matraque de mettre
la tente
et puis tu dois marcher un fake respaud
rester vivant vous avez quand même envie
de faire pipi de temps en temps écoute
situation avec 500 c'est pas évident
parce que tu ne trouves pas déjà c'est
ça fait six mois que ccc 5 litres de
l'eau l'eau avant dormir je bois 5
litres fait ça me permet de réveiller
chaque une heure chacune heure et demie
comme ça gèle pas en dormant et puis je
sais que je vais rêver peut-être
autrement tout content de tout en
dormant moins 50 au moins 60 il ya si tu
dors trop profondément
un fait que tu peux jamais tu vas jamais
rêvé tu vas j'allais se dit que la seule
façon de vraiment baissé c'est d'avoir
envie pisser et puis la piste et en
bouteille 1
et puis parce que la piste est à 36
degrés je prends les bouteilles et puis
je chauffe mes pieds parce que mes pieds
à l'extrémité les sacs de couchage et vu
deux
je veux dire un truc quand tu lis le
bouc ah ouais je me suis dit c'est moi
ce que tu dis parce que je me suis
battue tout est bidon un moment c'est
tellement énorme ce qu'il a vécu que tu
dis c'est pas là ça jamais ça jamais été
faire pendant l'hiver et c'est
extraordinaire est alors affecté chaude
tutu saab se passe à l'intérieur attend
tu peux en disant l'hiver si tu vas dors
tu veux bcta pantalon et puis tu peux
sortir peut-être 10% et puis tu donnes
tu veux mais tu sais impossible
d'exposer des petits la peau ta peau a
dit le pr thure en moins 50 et moins 60
se dit que tout passe à l'intérieur la
tante y avait une trappe à l'intérieur
attentes
je pouvais faire un petit trou voix quan
chi automne intérieur l'attendre un sens
en charge elle tout de suite quoi ah
ouais c'est solide comme ça tu nourrir
un peu des animaux alors c'est
incroyable le pire de tous et contient
un incendie parce qu'à un moment votre
bouteille de benzin tombe sur le réchaud
et alors là en plein milieu de cette
immensité glacée et ultra froide
il ya un incendie et tout brûle quoi
c'est à dire la tante brûle tout brûler
il y a moi j'ai rempli j'ai mes
bouteilles mois 45
et puis un jour il y avait là des
voitures ça a chauffé à -29 et puis à
moi vente
il y a jusqu'à moi 45 il ya 25 degrés de
différence
1 et puis là tu vois un peu difficulty a
commandité qui espère exquis expansé
puis là parce qu'il faisait chaud
il fume prenez-la volume et puis avec
mon réchaud de l'intérieur l'attend
quand j'ai ouvert
en fait mon bouteille s'agiter partout
s'agit qu'un peu sur moi ça j'écris sur
mon sac de couchage et en plein feu
l'implant plein milieu de de l'article
sexo dia alors après bon je vais pas
tout raconter mais c'est vraiment génial
il ya l'alaska le détroit de béring la
sibérie fait tout le tour
le mec est alors parfois vous vous
tombez pas ce que votre corps refuse de
vous obéir et là vous avez la tentation
de ne plus vous relevez la tentation de
vous laisser mourir et
il vous entendez la voix de vos filles
des problèmes c'est que quand quand on
commence de gel et on s'est vraiment pas
créé ce qui se passe avec nous et puis
là c'était après douze heures de marche
voyait nuages noirs qui arrive sur
l'horizon et puis je disais est ce que
j'ai essayé de marcher à travers de ce
ton père essaye de mekla tongs
maintenant et puis j'ai fait une erreur
je disais mais je veux marcher à travers
parce que je peux gagner peut-être cinq
à dix kilomètres
et puis là c'est sûr que la tempête a
pas arrêté pour trois jours et puis
j'avais moment que physiquement tu es tu
étais tellement fatigué la luge derrière
toi pezula cent cinquante à soixante 160
kg et puis un moment que tu peux plus
tirés sains et puis là contre yvon
remonte à 150 km à leur niveau est venue
d'une offre moi je marche vers l'ouest
ça roule d'un fête foraine ou sur la
glace
et puis tu aimes barque avec et puis là
tu dis mais je peux me lève et je sois
encore amassé un divan je préfère de
mourir parce que comme ça je n'ai plus
besoin de tirer la juge je n'ai plus
besoin de faire quoi que ce soit je peux
que rêver ici
il est vraiment aller au bout le vaincu
a répété et puis on a une vie pépère
finalement c'est ce que tu dis quand tu
dis son bouquin tu dis finalement n'est
pas si malheureux alors il ya des
moments incroyables parce que comme
étant en russie vous marchez 300 km sur
un gazoduc
l'ours a l'air facile tu dit marchons
gazoduc sauf qu'en dessous il ya ya ya
15-20 m quoi ce n'est pas tant des
rivières oui mais pas toujours
sinon mais c'est le bien sûr l'accord le
pire de tout c'est qu'un joueur en 40
un joli il ya un camion je crois que
sensuelle en arrivant il ya un camion
qu'il prend avec son kayak et qui lui
fait gagner du temps alors évidemment il
dépose le kayak mais je dis quand même
le pari que j'ai fait c'est de faire
tout ce voyage sans aide d'engins à
moteur donc une fois qu'il a déposé son
kayak il se fait ramener t'imagines l'a
déjà fait
dix neuf mille bornes mais qu il serait
ramené à l'endroit où il était pour
faire la différence à pied quoi juste
faut tenir parole juste pour respecter
le deal quoi main je crois que c'est ça
la en été mais ça va loin
[Musique]
ep
bravo il pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu